now probably morty loves them morty oh
uh hypothetical grandson we go on
adventures with you're one of those
creeps who moves in with abandoned adult
bats it's more complicated whoa
you live with the version okay so that
was better get off your head that was
legit
it was real diane died
we have some implications to discuss
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season five episode eight rick
turnell friendshine of the spotless mort
an eternal sunshine parody dives deep
into bird person and rick's memories
giving us our clearest look yet at
rick's actual past confirming that beth
and rick's wife diane were actually
killed in their original universe and
possibly the theory that rick is a
grown-up morty finally some canonical
implications to actually discuss for
rick and morty thanks charlie kaufman
logic but for real what off
this is rick splained our rick and morty
after show where we reassemble your
broken memories into an episode of
something that actually makes more sense
what do you think about it i'm eric voss
and my easter egg breakdown of all the
details you missed is coming tomorrow
tommy beck told us out this week instead
filling in is a wonderful jessica
clemons
welcome hi
i'm excited excited about rick and morty
yeah i am too this uh episode actually
seems like whoa they're they're making
some moves we got some weight
to raise history here super stoked to be
on the saddest episode of the season so
far i know what a bummer well it's like
this and planet tina for me like we're
breaking our hearts about morty and now
we're breaking our hearts about rick
whoever wrote that episode the writing
at the end for planet tina i went wait
this isn't funny
this is sad i was like this is a child
dealing with our break for the first
time all right well just break down what
happened this episode okay let's get
into it so rick resurrects bird person's
body but bp's mind is lost inside his
subconscious rick goes inside to find bp
in his scattered memories rick teams up
with young rick and finds bp trying to
implode his subconscious to expedite his
death they revisit the memory of the
battle of bloodridge which ends with bp
rejecting rick's friendship they track
down bp with tammy and reveal that bp
has a child now willing to live rick
uses his own painful memories to lily
pad back to the exit point back in
reality bp calls out rick for only
telling him about his child to save
himself and ditches him rick goes back
inside himself to hang out with young
rick in his own childhood memory and
bird person's daughter brawls with other
prisoners in the federation custody it
is
so much that went on this episode yeah i
know thank you for distilling it because
it moves so fast it's just understanding
what they're doing at any moment is kind
of a struggle this isn't an episode too
where you can watch like which is
watch this episode that we're talking
about right now but you also need to
watch the actual episode because there's
every second of it is like tangential to
the entire series and i you can't miss a
beat you can't miss a beat yeah it
almost is like the way avengers end game
in its second act just kind of revisited
past mcu moments but was like very clear
when and where they were going there was
no subtlety at all this is super subtle
it references the season three premiere
it uh talks about the season one finale
where they're having the house party
because that's where bird person tammy
met
and the morty's mind blowers uh device
comes back there's all these little
things that like the writers had had
full understanding of everything that
has happened in the series and just blew
it all up because like uh the band the
flesh curtains band uh that uh squanchy
and bird person and rick were all part
of you see the origins of that uh it's
pretty wild i
we might talk about it favorite part is
also just that we finally talk about um
gear whatever isn't it oh right yeah
like you're doing
we we were freedom fighters with his
older brother you think we actually
wanted to hang out with him i was like
oh we finally get into it we get into
how much we just don't like him and he's
just a little brother of our actual best
friend i feel guilty for you know
uh we miss our old friend kill his
memory at the funeral
it was so funny oh it's so sad
well since this episode is set inside bp
and rick's actual memories we can
interpret these events as part of rick's
actual backstory i think we have
canonicity here uh the series so rarely
confirms anything being canon on this
show but this episode i think they
really want us to understand how this
connects to rick's backstory and we have
a sense of how rick became the rick that
we know uh i think it's pretty
groundbreaking before we talk about that
though one of the best ways you can
support us is to check out our merch at
new rockstarsmerch.com
we have a full lineup of suicide squad
inspired merch this month including our
bad company ladies obsession shirt and a
really cool king shark jaws mashup
support this channel get yourself some
great swag by going to new
rockstarsmerch.com
okay so has rick's past with diane
finally been confirmed yeah i think we
all heard correctly this episode rick's
younger memory self calls him out for
quote living with a version of our dead
daughter now rick back in the season
three premiere told that ground from
light that whole memory of diane's death
and beth's death was like a subjective
that he's using to trick him uh
so we've never really been certain how
legit that was but by young memory rick
saying our dead daughter he was kind of
treating that as being like the default
the normal
course of events of history um which
means those events were likely real or
at least close to real there was
probably something that was off about it
like the exact math that was uh that was
went into his technology that's probably
what he altered about it but i think
diane and beth really did die and rick
left that reality behind to some new
reality where they didn't die and i
think they're leaning into this because
diane has come back since like when mr
nimbus uh this season brought her up in
the season five premiere if diane were
alive today what was she the
established canadical backstory with me
you redlock and then earlier this
episode when rick enters a bar shootout
with the younger rick and a bird person
versus four sci-fi ricks the other guy's
like killing us won't bring her back
and that was before they they brought up
the whole thing about beth being dead so
i think that would have to be shortly
after the diane flashback um and the
alternate rick that rick met did have
like an 80s sci-fi look you know he had
the beginnings of a moment so i think
that could have been his gang that
they're in the shootout with now uh and
now rick in this moment is on a
vengeance war path that would evolve
into his hatred of the citadel of bricks
yes and then jess crazy detailed i
spotted this episode i don't know if you
saw this uh when they revisit squanchy's
stand-up phase which is so funny because
jess and i know each other from uh
beyond to sketch team we have a lot of
friends who are like doing stand-up
headlines yes you do have to go support
them oh all of our friends are super
funny all of our friends are good oh
well they're not squan cheese they're
not squashies but we we do know some
people who have been squanchies who go
through some stand-up phase and you just
gotta support them because
you just got to see that part hit a
little hard but then also that that rick
line was so good of like oh god i'm a
memory and i didn't have to stay in like
a memory of this like i'm the worst
memory like nothing yeah oh my god it's
so funny well that rick who said that
has the same exact hair and specifically
blue pants
as his diane flashback self and in that
episode he's like oh i used to wear blue
pants that was a very specific era of
time so i think um rick might have had
time to support squanchy stand up
because he just started to become
friends with them in that moment and
that's often what you do with new
friends is you support their their
creative endeavors more than you would
if someone you've been friends with for
a long time that's kind of a weird irony
paradox the longer you're friends with
some of them less likely you're going to
go watch their comedy sure
um and more specifically he had no wife
or kid at home anymore so yeah we are we
all know friends who have gone through
breakups or or tragic events and
suddenly their schedule has opened up a
lot oh yeah um in a horrible way but
horrible true in a horrible way it's
valid now just the episode ended with
rick as a young boy who looked a lot
like morty he wore a yellow shirt his
pants his hair almost was kind of
morty-esque and the fact that he was so
horny and wants to like go downstairs to
peep like
do you think this could be a hint to the
theories out there that morty might be
growing up to become a rick and that
it's all part of a time loop or
something i don't think so i love that i
love that theory because it's it's just
crazy and insane and i love those
theories that people have been creating
for rick and morty i just think rick was
a whimsical child and he was happy and
if anything we should look at it and be
like look at how happy he was and
outgoing and how sad and depressing he
hates himself now that's what we really
need to look at and that was the part
that i really liked about this episode
was he kept referring to the memory of
his young self and being like you are
gonna be me like you are gonna be me one
day be prepared for that like i don't
become you you become me and you have
all this like energy and happiness but
it's gonna go away it's gonna
deteriorate once you recognize what the
real world is really there for so i
don't think it's gonna be a whimsical
morty i just or i don't think he's gonna
i just think it's there to be like look
at how
sweet this boy was right if anything i
and i'm also just like more curious
about the diane and beth dying situation
because i love the idea from the last
season that it was just like a rick
being like you don't need your family
you need to do all this and him being
like no i like my family i love them
they're pretty cool and him being like
well i'm gonna kill you because it seems
like a rick thing to do to be like
selfish enough to kill his own family in
a different timeline he would justify it
as i'm liberating you to make myself
more powerful because the more
independent ricks that exist in the
multiverse the more powerful i become
yeah and there's also there's so many
different versions of rick this could
just be like uh not we've already done
mafia ricks but this could be just like
uh the street watch rick i don't know
it's something it could be it could be
any kind of rick so that's why i was
like i like the idea of that i i think
the conclusion is definitely this is why
he hates the citadel um it's that
it's a bunch of ricks and there's no
rick that hates more than himself
because his self killed his family and
so that's where i was like sticking with
the entire episode of being like
how did they die and when are they going
to find out that they're dead
i was like when are they going to figure
it out oh but yeah that's 92 cents i'm
with you though on this idea of uh i
don't think rick and morty are going to
be revealed as the same character i
think there are certainly commonalities
between them and the show loves
exploring those ins and outs and i think
the way they animated uh young rick in
that like i think it was deliberately
meant to be like yeah he was similar to
morty but in the same way that like
grandsons and uh grandfathers
have similar uh
ways similar life stages that they go
through every boy was like a young horny
teenager at some point yeah it's not
hard to like that's not hard to make up
right right i also think that like uh
they are exploring more how morty is a
different person than rick yes
just because they change over the course
of the show which is good doesn't mean
that what they're changing into is the
exact same human being i i think like
morty is changing to a more
sophisticated morty rick is changing to
a more sophisticated rick uh and i love
that i love that they're distinct uh
personalities and philosophies because
it gives the show more complexity um
otherwise it would be kind of like the
the bat the worst version of the
theories of during loki that they're
saying every character is a loki variant
like mobius is a loki variant here's why
branslayer is a loki variant here's why
it's like no having diversity of
philosophy and characterization is a
good thing you know yeah also i guess
the only hole i see in that theory is
also like we have all these millions of
mortys are they supposed to become
millions of ricks eventually because we
have all the different variations of i
think rick is just rick and morty is
just morty to play devil's advocate i
think the theory that's being pitched is
that in this particular case oh the
morty is becoming the rick or you could
say because it's a multiverse that like
the only reason morty's exist uh but
like all of them become like branch
versions of themselves that don't become
rick it's one of these things where
anything could be anything right i could
see the writers doing that eventually i
feel like the writers for rick and morty
appease the audience so much and i love
that more than anything oh we're
listening to you guys like we have to we
have so many seasons left of this show
right we're going to listen to you guys
so i could see them doing it eventually
down the line but i think right now i
love more than anything that they're
just exploring who like the planetina
part i loved so much because i was just
like oh we're giving morty a chance like
we we're finally giving him a chance of
like love in this real aspect and i want
to see how he reacts to it and we just
take apart rick and morty every time
there's a separate rick and morty
episode i really like it cause i'm like
we're getting these two different people
and i get to learn more about them even
though it's like summer's always with
rick in those episodes but i'm still
like oh we get to know more about these
people so hopefully it doesn't happen
just to uh recap the new rick history
that has been confirmed by this episode
just to kind of stitch together what
seems now to be canon about his
background so he did have a wife diane
and a daughter beth they were killed by
a bomb from an alternate dimension most
likely uh and then rick avenges them by
declaring war on other ricks and becomes
uh one of the more
homicidal ricks in the multiverse rick
during this time befriends bird person
at a burning man fest uh they start a
band with squanchy it's called the flesh
curtains uh and then also at some point
later they mobilize into like a commando
unit that ends with the battle of blood
ridge and bird person rejects rick's
friendship um in some weird twist of
fate this could be an alternate uh
realities what led rick to
create the multiverse uh because
the reason why that alternate reality
rick told rick to leave his family is
kind of the same pitch that rick was
giving a bird person come with me
explore realities where anything is
possible so i wonder if it like
that's what led
rick that rick to kill that diane and
force every other rick to be alone so
that he could try to have friends to
explore the multiverse with like if
my intellectual equal in another turns
me down the intellectual equal in myself
must say yes yeah oh god that's even
rick is becoming a more depressing
person and we have to recognize that so
this is something that is very valid of
him being like uh i have to search the
world for a companion to the point of
killing my own companions yeah oh
probably but i do love how part of this
grew part of the commando unit was gear
dude who's like a cooler version of
gearhead uh but we're feeling like
mullet yeah
yeah kind of a rambo look um but his uh
the only reason they hung out with him
is that it was just his little brother
which is just so sad now sometime later
rick swaps into a new reality where beth
is still alive but was abandoned so i
think the idea was that rick in that
reality rather than being a good family
man earlier on decided to leave them
behind and be an absent father to them
we know that this was before because
young rick who was in that commando unit
uh had not yet reunited with beth he was
like oh you're one of those but he was
like aware that there are other ricks
who do this
so i don't think he had decided in his
older age i think that must have been
after bird person turned him down
at the bloodridge battle um but we also
know from other clues on the show's
history that rick was there for morty's
birth there was like a picture of him
holding a baby morty and and like a
memory you know uh and then uh you know
normal course of their life rick and
morty become partners going adventures
but at some point before morty started
to go on adventures with them he did
have a previous assistant named kyle mr
nimbus brought that up i liked your
other one more what was his name kyle
what nothing and there is a promo for a
later episode this season where there's
like the the wheel that rick spins and
kyle is mentioned on that wheel i wonder
if kyle is gonna show up we know from
season the season one rick potion number
nine episode the c-137 universe gets
cronenberg so they gotta swap into yet
another one and then the bird person
marries tammy at the end of season two
she betrays him reveals herself as a
federation agent
squanchy and per person die rick turns
himself into the federation but ends up
destroying most of the federation and
the citadel though apparently both
rebuild the citadel obviously rebuilds
we weren't sure about the federation but
now it seems like the federation is
actually always around bird person gets
turned into the cyborg phoenix person
that's what that happens and then that
pairing returns at the end of season
four along the same time when beth's
clone returns spacebath and that was
from the end of season three when you
learned that beth was cloned and then
tammy and phoenix person attack uh bird
keeps phoenix persons parts and restores
him as bird person in this episode the
takeaways are uh federation's always
around uh federation's never fully wiped
out and rick really did have a wife
diane who died i don't know if we'll
ever see it it's probably next season
we'll probably get oh yeah i can't wait
i can't wait i can't wait we need to
know diane yeah i think it it's just a
fun character that we could explore on
the show um we don't need to go too much
whatever she was another scientist yeah
okay yeah what if she's one who like
inspired a lot of his uh
technological breakthroughs
i actually have another theory about
where diane could be um but first some
people who helped us make this episode
thank you to our sponsor keeps two out
of three men will experience hair loss
by the time they turn 35 well keeps
offers a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door and discreet
packaging every three months you don't
have to leave your home which might be
necessary if the us army is surrounding
your home because you destroy the
constitution the treatments are
affordable and start at just ten dollars
per month and keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss prevention medications out
there keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key and treatments can take four to
six months to see results so act fast
and hit up keeps now if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash ricksplain to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com for
explain to get your first month for free
k-e-e-p-s dot com flush or explain we
also want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode however heads up
blue chew have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable format at a fraction of the
cost blue shoe is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package you signed up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days your licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient strength and if you
hate swallowing pills good news blue
chew is chewable just like it says in
the name so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code we explained to check out
just pay the five dollars of shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code rxplain
to receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
luchu for sponsoring the show this show
is also sponsored by better help is
there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals we've all been
there at some point betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help it
is professional counseling done securely
online there is a broad range of
expertise available for clients
worldwide log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor you
won't ever have to sit in a comfortable
waiting room or look for parking better
help makes it easy and free to change
counselors if you need to it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life
today
visit betterhelp.com
explained that's better h-e-l-p and join
the over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for explained audience get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
explained all right jess i mentioned
kyle
uh
we are getting to know rick's backstory
they're starting to pin down some
canonical historical points do you think
rick's past assistant kyle will appear
this season i hope he does i think it
will is especially if we do like a
little flashback or something we'll get
into it just because it's a very funny
side bit and i won't it's gonna be so
funny he's probably gonna die uh yeah
right because he's not around anymore or
he or he quit like he just like refused
it he put out a restraining order on
rick or something like that he's like i
will not work for you or like the uh
pirates of the pancreas he just starts
working for someone else he starts
working for somebody else and rick gets
really upset working for rick would be
the worst thing in the world so i bet
it's gonna be an episode of just like
him being like struggling really hard um
working with morty and not liking morty
either
like i want to see like rick as like a
horrible boss or a um a devil wears
prada relationship where uh he refused
to give kyle like a good recommendation
like after he left he was just bitter to
his ex assistant and like has been
trying to doom his career whatever new
job he moves on to he gives him like a
shitty recommendation or gosh he'll
probably move to another rick i'll just
find like another version of her
my favorite the yo-yo rick
what if he just like moved to someone
like that well just this season has
explored the characters of rick's a.i
and his car and got to know her and now
we meet the ai in his garage
do you think rick could have some other
kind of ai in one of his other repeated
uh settings or devices and his settings
are different i hope his portal gun it
cannot oh
then it would just be leading
the car episode she went off the rails
yeah she was like we're just gonna go
crazy so i was like i'm and then oh my
god when she put her she took her like
memory bank and
broke into like the lawyer's back of
their head and just started walking
around as a corpse i could maybe that
could be a situation where she becomes
more sentient and he allows her to like
be put into like a robot body um that
would be a fun episode but i do think
she's so fun to keep that i don't want
her to leave yeah she is yeah
i i think that is a fun character here
here's my theory that i mentioned
earlier what if the ai in the car and
the ai in the garage are both forms of
diane i was able to say what should be
like diane's voice yeah you know like
that like we did hear diane's voice
maybe he has like a computerized version
of her soul and that's where the ai
comes from is like her sentience that
he's either trying to replicate it or he
was actually able to capture and distill
it uh and now that's like how where who
he spends all of his time with that's
why they both kind of have this
adventurous spirit to them why the
garage ai is so desperate to try to get
like a corporeal forum that's
independent of a brick is to try to
break free
oh
gross side note what if she becomes like
in love with morty
and
she does anything in her being to become
in a relationship with morty um aka goes
into another sex spot um
maybe personally we don't know i hope
she's i just wanted to stay this is the
new character for this season that i'm
glad they're bringing in other than gene
the neighbor
i knew we were gonna see him they kept
bringing them back up you know this
episode he brought all the batteries and
stuff what who is that why would he come
here i don't know what he's doing here
poor gene for poor gene well apparently
the federation is alive and well
imprisoning bird person's daughter so
what do you think we can expect from her
in a future episode what if she's
treated like jaguar's daughter
what if she just goes missing or she
becomes in the okay so like jaguar's
jaguar yeah his daughter they were like
we killed her but a different situation
but same
mapping of just like what would happen
in a like um an action movie if someone
was looking for their missing daughter
so what if they're using the daughter as
a weapon in the federation to replace
tammy because what can fight another
bird person than a bird person
especially a bird person that's related
to this bird person she's a child right
now but by the time bird person probably
gets her she's gonna be like a teenager
and she's just gonna be like brainwashed
by the federation but also slightly um
slightly agreeing with like well you're
my dad and you left me
so i don't like you either
um and it'll be like a really sad
episode of like bird person can't see
his daughter and she just wants to kill
her dad
i love that um like the idea that uh
tammy could have been a similar person
like some orphan or some abandoned kid
who just gets raised by the federation
and indoctrinated with their views i
mean uh in a way like this show is about
fathers and daughters and the way beth
her relationship with rick was kind of
uh forged by his absence um
i could see
a bird person's daughter being kind of
what space beth was you know just this
um
that might be like the episode of rick
or even beth being like talking to bird
person's daughter and being like you
don't want to do this
like i've been chasing my dad forever
and i finally got him and he sucks like
you your dad actually loves you please
don't let this leave but also she's a
fighting machine you saw her in prison
smacking that person with a yeah that
thing with a lunch tray and she's like
five i was like okay
she's angry yeah yeah she's vicious i do
like that line why do we put all the
violent ones together yeah he's like
yeah i don't make the rules
federation is so stupid any other uh
favorite standout moments to you this
episode jess the squanchy
comedy show the stand-up the ai garage i
was so i was obsessed with the writing
for her i was like this is such a funny
bit and i want her to stay in it at all
times i just love the uh using the
morty's mind blower device um bringing
it back from a point in the timeline
that was the end of season one when the
house party was happening and using it
to suck out memories that you then fire
back out as like grenades that open
portals back into memories and just the
fact that i can say to lily pad back to
the exit point it's like that's such a
cool way to like move your characters
through a plot and this yeah the fact
that has to be rick's like tragic
memories in order to say goodbye to bird
person they asked to relive some of
their darker moments i just thought that
was so cool
the fight of bloodridge um i was like i
was like oh this gave me exactly what it
was getting ready for i kept ramping up
it was like this is our vietnam and it
was like you need to get better ideals
but i i was like the fighting scene was
so fun okay i guess my question is whose
side are you on bird persons are ricks
when bird person was like
no if it doesn't matter then why are you
here right um because when i watched it
i was like i'm on bird person's side but
then when rick was when younger rick was
like he's a dick why are you friends
with him i was like
was he being a dick i i just thought it
was genuinely like i'd be like yeah why
are you here our friendship doesn't mean
anything obviously to you since you
don't think anything matters
yeah i um i feel like this show is kind
of
saying don't be on rick's side uh find
your humanity and realize all these
people are trying to tell rick
you don't need to
go too far get too greedy with your
affinity to explore the multiverse real
talk appreciate what you have
that's true that is true they are trying
to remember he's not good right but then
for
looking at where bird person goes after
that it's not like his
you know life is any better for him how
he hooks up with tammy you know like i
don't know i'm i'm on rick's side
ultimately i think i think if bird
person stayed with him uh rick's life
would not have been as toxic
that is true that is 100 sure if bird
person would have stayed with yeah i
guess that's true knowing rick is rick
and bird person did react that way and
he still did like even when rick was
like when bird person was like would you
have brought up my daughter to me i was
like no he was trying to get you to come
off of just friendship it took him
having to stoop to something much lower
in order for you to leave your own mind
like he had to like
i i thought friendship would sell too
but it didn't i guess your daughter had
to no yes to his daughter well and you
know it's one of those things where yes
the reason i told you was self-serving
uh yeah but i don't know sometimes the
ends can justify the means with these
things like sometimes what also helps me
will also help you and there's nothing
wrong with that like i didn't see
anything wrong with that part that part
yeah i was like oh yeah yeah this one we
can't expect everyone to uh
to be completely selfless in all of our
engagements technically everything we do
would be self-serving in a way because
anytime we form a friendship
uh we're not just helping out a friend
you are going to be serving your own
interests by giving yourself a friend to
hang out with
100 so i hope they don't make me choose
between the two eventually but they said
you are right they have been like
reiterating like rick is a bad person
you shouldn't be rooting for rick and
it's like
okay but like
but all these people kind of suck
yeah well honestly
honestly the only person that i like
which is sad that i can actually like be
like this is me is summer and summer's
the worst person summer's awful so it
sucks so what was there something she
said one episode this season where i was
like why am i summer i was like so mad
at myself i was like god i'm such a
summer and it hurts me
for me it's jerry it's like why am i
sorry see i'd rather be a summer than a
jerry me too
me too
oh my god the episode with the demon the
hell people
[Laughter]
jerry's so pathetic sorry boss you're
not that is me that is me you're not
jerry to me every social engagement i go
to i'm the schmuck at the dinner for
schmuck no you remind me more of morty
when he got his uh like non-confidence
taken away
oh from the oh the uh the toxic morty
yeah yeah when he got his toxic part
taken out you remind me of confident
morty
wolf of wall street i think i'd still
rather be jerry in that case
yeah uh god bless the show for giving us
so many characters and incarnations of
characters that uh speak to our worst
selves that we can relate with
um well that is it for this episode of
rick explained jess thank you so much
for joining us this week it's so great
to talk to you about this show my easter
egg breakdown of all the little details
you missed in the episode will come out
tomorrow you can follow jess at lulu
underscore clemens
on uh which one is that is that on
twitter or it's on twitter luluclement's
everywhere i'm sure you'll find
clementine everywhere else
um follow me at ea voss follow new
rockstars subscribe to or explain
wherever you get your podcast thank you
for watching and we will close with our
favorite moment of the episode
uh the night we met gross on my
workbench quantity used that's what some
closets are for
[Music]
you